I uncovered a 500 million dollar Ponzi
scheme and by the end of this three-part
series we will expose offshore money
fraud and confront the man behind it all
yeah I get arrested and then what I win
because they're dead
but before we do that let's start at the
beginning after my Logan Paul
investigation I was bored and I'd been
drinking a little too much that's it
coffee I'm cutting you off you've had
way too much why yes
however the truth was I just needed a
new case
[Music]
I woke up hungover with a text about
something called traitor's domain
I hadn't heard of it this person told me
that a lot of people and celebrities had
their money locked up in it and they
were hoping it wasn't all gone I decided
it was the perfect case to get back in
the game
it's time to investigate Traders domain
all right back in the 10 million dollar
Studio I've got their website pulled up
here and it says they're gonna maximize
your financial potential and claim that
in three years they made returns of 473
000 percent according to their website
they do this by being a Forex broker
which is fine but what's strange is that
they're an offshore company which means
technically they can't serve U.S
investors if they wanted to because
they're located in Saint Vincent which
is unregulated uh but if that's the case
how did our friend here even get
involved and what he told me was this
quote Brandon is who brought me into the
fund these are the sponsors but of
course that begs the question who is
Brandon Sims and what is a sponsor well
we're gonna go to the conspiracy board
because I can tell it's going to get
complicated to see what we're working
with so far we have an investor going
into Traders domain through Brandon Sims
but where does the money go oh well I
asked and what he told me was this it
didn't go offshore at all to trader's
domain it went to a company called CCAP
Holdings LLC in the United States we'll
add that as well
now if that wasn't weird enough in
addition Brandon wanted to hide what the
money was even for that was invested
he's told our investor this don't put
investment in memo just put services for
you
now this is where things get weird
because it turns out CCAP Holdings isn't
owned by Brandon Sims at all it's also
not owned by Traders domain it's owned
by a man named tin Tran now when you
look up who tin Tran is he's basically a
ghost there's essentially only one
article about him about him running a
weed growing operation which he was
arrested for so what exactly is going on
here well to find out I got a couple
calls with two TV celebrities who said
they put money in Traders domain and
lost it as well and hopefully they can
help us figure this out my name is Faith
Morgan I lost 950 000 in Traders domain
hi my name is Jamil damji I invested a
million dollars into Traders domain I
have never taken a withdrawal out and
I've lost all million dollars and I
wanted to ask how these two got involved
with Trader's domain so I come to learn
of this opportunity this investment
opportunity at a mastermind in Miami
Florida I was invited there by Pete
Vargas who is on Grant cardone's team
Pete Vargas came to me and said hey I've
got this thing that I'm making really
good money on and you and Jamil should
get involved and this is where we meet
the individual by the name of Holton
bugs they showed me their accounts and
they're like look at this we're pulling
money in every single month look at this
look at this look at this he gets into
this incredible story of millions of
dollars of profits that he's been able
to make in the world of day trading and
shows us some accounts some of these
accounts had phenomenal like just
mind-bending balances in it one of them
was over 80 million dollars there was
another account that he showed us that
had over 650 million dollars he had said
that someone had offered him 650 million
dollars to buy his trading bot
apparently this bot was the you know
incredible Tech technology that was
making these fantastic returns and the
bot never had a losing day but he's
showing us the software it's not just
screenshots it's like actual software
that I've never seen before and it's
called Trader's domain I make a decision
that I would invest initially five
hundred thousand dollars I talked to
Holton and his team and they send me
wire instructions and on those wire
instructions I am implicitly and very
specifically told you know how to send
the wire who to send the wire to what to
write in the memo now what I found
interesting about this is despite this
being a new sponsor
look at who they're sending money to
once again CCAP Holdings through Holton
bugs this time we'll put him on the
board as well from what I can tell
online he's a small time MLM promoter my
goal was to share with them how to
properly use the Lamborghini look at the
purpose of the wire that was sent again
once again it says services not
investment which is exactly what Brandon
Sims instructed his clients to do as
well and this is where I was confused
because the more people I talked to the
more felt like everyone kind of had the
same story take another sponsor I found
for Trader's domain which I found from
our First Source once again Mike Sims
now he claims Trader's domain was his
hedge fund I've invested in was your
hedge fund correct yes correct it's so
crazy I don't I'm just learning what it
is only because we started talking about
it I didn't understand it yeah but I
trusted it only because I trusted your
company and I trusted all the other
people that invested all my friends and
it was like a little fear of loss like
yo y'all not gonna get this bro so it's
fun I'm up 60 which is in what is it
maybe a two months
but no no losing months now this all
sounds great and according to leaked
texts from Mike's assistant we find out
that these investment accounts people
are putting in look identical to the
ones on Trader's domain so it doesn't
take a genius to figure out Mike Sims is
putting some people's money into Traders
domain and it looks like he's claiming
it's his hedge fund but how could that
be if Holton bug says it's his trading
Bots and still yet another sponsor for
Traders domain called goldbridge said
they were following a Master Trader this
is goldbridge we've said that
um our protocol mirrors uh the results
of a Master Trader and to this day we
haven't had a red day this is real stuff
we're not using New Capital uh you know
to pay off the old investor like there's
there's no Ponzi ah yes nothing says
it's not a Ponzi scheme like saying hey
guys this is not a Ponzi scheme now of
course I went ahead and put everyone on
the board here but the more people I
talk to just the more confusing it got
like who's running this thing and what
is it is Trader's domain a hedge fund is
it Forex is it a bot what's going on
seems like not even the investors know
he said like it's a bot uh that they're
using to trade um gold very credible
Wall Street Trader done this for a long
time and experienced uh Trader who had
built a large Network made a lot of
money for people that um I knew and
personally trusted it really feels like
the more sponsors that I find the more
confusing it's getting and the details
even when they seem to line up always
slightly varied for example if you put
in your money with Alex Santi of
centurion Capital they said they were
going to use an expert advisor trading
bot which might sound similar to algo
Capital another sponsor who said they
were using a trading bot as well but
with the twist I thought yeah basically
they described it as a bot that was
configured with settings they had it
down where they would win like almost
all the time and there was a Master
Trader overseeing the bots so this time
there's another Master Trader involved I
mean try trying to find the truth feels
like I'm trying to grab smoke or
something every time I thought I
understood what was going on I'd hear a
new story I even found one about nfts
they said they were investing in nfts
but really the money was just getting
siphoned off to trader's domain and part
of the reason I'm going through all
these examples with you is to show you
the absolute insanity of this
everybody's feeding money into the same
place all under different reasons with
different stories but they did have one
thing in common you see everybody was
making lots of money and getting very
rich with Traders domain at least at
first when I meet dozens of people all
of whom have been in this platform for
over a year all of whom are saying that
they've pulled out more than their
principal those people have unbelievable
stories of like yeah I've made this much
money I've done this much I've pulled
this out and not just stories but like
hey yeah here's my bank account I got a
wired two months ago so my brother
started with 10 grand and with that 10
grand bro he's made way over a hundred
thousand dollars but bro all the way up
to that last October he's been able to
cash out no problem and he's quadruple
made so much of it made profit and this
is the reason people were throwing their
money into Traders domain they saw their
friends and family getting paid out
legitimately but
like all good things that came to an end
over time payments started to get
delayed and people started noticing
something odd the only time he noticed
that it started slowing down was in
October where they started talking about
the 20 days but it took them more than
20 days and so what ends up happening is
one day we're looking at our phones and
all of a sudden we're losing and we're
not just losing a little bit our
accounts are on drawdown like 50 percent
and then Pace calls me he's like ah this
is where the this is where the rug gets
pulled out from underneath us man I
always I felt like something was wrong
and I feel like this is where the road's
gonna get pulled out from underneath us
it felt like that day I was getting I
was feeling sick I'm like man I damn it
we got scammed and then all of a sudden
everything magically got erased
and they said oh the server is refreshed
we had to refresh the servers like that
somehow changed all the trades they said
no it's the aggregator the way the
aggregator communicates from the
platform to metatrader5 the data gets
scrambled and then it gets screwed up
for the whole day and then by the end of
the day I actually made money he just
changed the trades he just changed the
exit you know dollar amount that he that
he took
on that trade now this was alarming
trades can't change after the fact
losses don't just magically become
profits that's impossible
and people were confused why were their
withdrawals getting delayed if they were
still making money and that's when
people started to panic withdrawal they
wanted their money out and this is when
things went from bad to worse because
payments stopped coming altogether and
the cftc issued a red list for Trader's
domain for quote accepting funds from
U.S customers which as we said is
illegal and a few months later as I'm
investigating this an official
investigation is announced as well quote
cftc charges several people and
companies in an 145 million dollar Ponzi
scheme and in that report they named
somebody we know tin Tran the owner of
CCAP Holdings according to this document
tin Tran quote operated a fraudulent
scheme from approximately April 2020 to
the present he directly accepted at
least 144 million dollars from
approximately 913 pool participants not
only that we also also see another
familiar face Mike Sims or Michael
Shannon Sims who is also mentioned as
one of the promoters so I guess at this
point you're probably wondering well hey
look I guess they caught him right case
closed and that's what I thought too but
just as I was ready to give this whole
case up I started to hear a different
name that changed everything something
happened in November or October and
people just stopped getting money back
nobody's communicating with us nothing's
happening everybody that's involved
keeps telling us that we're in
ungrateful and that we're asking too
many questions and I told you I told
Jamil in like first week of January I
said we got scammed man these guys must
be running a Ponzi scheme or something's
going on when I started doing my own
researches about who the company what
the company is well the owner behind the
team behind it the audit team behind it
and that's when I find out there's this
one guy named dead who's making all the
trades and he's running this Ponzi
scheme we now learn of this Savant that
is the man behind Traders domain and so
this is the first time I ever hear the
name Ted safranco and I'm like who the
freak is Ted who's Ted
[Music]
coffeezilla I don't think he's ever
dealt with someone my size before and
nobody knows anything about his family
because they don't have the resources I
have
took me weeks to go through all the
documents
but eventually
patterns started to emerge
hi everyone my name is Ted I've been
working for many years now almost 15
years I wanted to have a lifestyle
change I wanted to get into something
different I mean this is sociopathic
Behavior right this is what a real
sociopath does give me a break I take a
flight to the UK right now and just show
up and curb stomp their heads I win
because they're dead
thank you